an advancement for girls right here in
America a year and a half ago the Boy
Scouts of America announced that girls
would be able to join its ranks and last
month the organization even altered the
program's name to accommodate that
change Carter Evans spoke with some of
the first young people to experience
this brave new world of scouting whether
they're playing music or a board game
going down 13-year old twin Sophia and
Brandon del Rosario are almost always
together but that changed when Brandon
entered the Boy Scouts when he was gone
on his campout it was weird like I can't
go with him I wanted to go to the gun
ranges and I wanted to go you know bow
and arrows the Girl Scouts don't do that
so the Girl Scouts can that's definitely
an option we just didn't end up doing
that I'm done with my troop it's not a
regular thing no welcome to our first
all-girl troop me so this winter Sophia
and thousands of other girls joined the
Boy Scouts program which changed his
name to Scouts BSA yeah and you like
that yeah I love that enrollment in the
Boy Scouts has been declining for years
but the organization says the decision
to allow girls is a response to demands
from busy parents who wanted one program
for the whole family
her brother supports the move I think
it's kind of cool actually girls and
boys will still be in their own troops
this is us girls
the twins BOM dia is scout master they
deserve to have the opportunity to both
enjoy that scouting experience as it was
meant to be and it was meant to be
single gender girls can now earn the
same merit badges and ranks as boys all
right for our patrol breakouts Sofia is
eager to earn the prestigious Eagle
Scout award high ambitions there that's
a lot of work yeah I'm ready I'm ready
to do it what do you hope other girls
take away from this I hope they can see
that they can do it too nothing holding
them back nope for CBS this morning
Saturday Carter Evans Rancho Santa
Margarita
you know I always wanted to be an Eagle
Scout my my dad was an Eagle Scout like
one of the youngest in the country at
the time and I have that Eagle Scout
badge framed in my home and gosh darn I
just missed it I wonder Michelle if you
can go back and join now I don't know if
there's an age limit well someone will
have a chance now that's a good thing
you missed it but someone will